candace is with us in sacramento hi
candace welcome to the ramsey show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm having a bit of a moral dilemma
that i'd love your advice on
um my son he's 19 years old
and we have decided as a family
including him in the decision-making
process
that you know he's got to be out on his
own on june 1st
we are a month away and he has no money
saved
and his plan is to go live on a friend's
couch
in the bad part of town where the
two-bedroom apartment that has five
people already
living in it so my husband and i are
debating do we give him more time
um he's shown no motivation to do
anything more
than to save um so we're just trying to
figure out
what to do and he's our first teenager
so we need some help
wow that's some hard discussions isn't
it
yeah yeah it is you know what we
he's a very unmotivated teenager um
just works with the drive-in making 1200
bucks a month
you know he could probably pay to run an
apartment with some friends but he's
done
nothing to save he's making dumb stupid
kid decisions
so we feel like maybe he won't go do
anything
if we don't kick him out so yeah what
are your thoughts
coleman what would your dad have done uh
well i
i feel like there needs to be some some
details here on the back story sounds
like there's been some behavior that's
violating some
values and some house rules that are
just at this point you and your husband
are saying this is non-negotiable and i
guess he's admitted to this and that's
where we got to the agreement
of june 1 is that a quick okay well
my dad my dad would have held to the
june 1
despite the fact that i would have been
woefully uh in this scenario if this is
me
and i'm not prepared he would have held
to it and
i i got to tell you i've got teenagers
myself and i'm trying to put myself into
this situation candace but i think that
failure in my life uh has been the
greatest
teacher and there's all different types
of failure here
and it's really hard as a parent uh i
don't have it figured out
and uh so the situation i hold to it you
and his dad and him are in the
discussion right
yes uh-huh yeah and we've been we we
decided this back in february after he
got fired from like his third
you know little minimum wage job um and
we were like
come on dude you gotta you gotta start
doing something and he was just you know
partying a lot uh coming home at all
hours he doesn't you know and
he was paying rent to us then and so i
was doing what you know ao has
had his dad do back in the day which was
you know he'd pay us rent and we'd save
it and then one day when he moved out we
were going to give it to him
but then he got a speeding ticket so you
know we were like well luckily we had
this money saved for you
uh we he he hears you in my office
every day all day so he knows the baby
steps
but there's you know there's nothing to
get his life together
so well um
you know i'm gonna take a page out of dr
john's book
that i might not have a year ago
and i'm probably going to write all of
this down
as a letter for him to have okay
and physically carry with him and the
letter also
includes not only the things that he's
not done
but it includes the fact that um any
time that you want some help
any time that you're ready to move
in the direction that are consistent
with the values that we've taught you
we will help you do that we are not
carving you out of our life as a matter
of fact we are heartbroken
i mean my heart's broken just listening
and i can't imagine anything harder and
sadder
um but uh
you you know that you run the danger if
you go the other direction of being an
enabler
and he'll be 29 and still doing the same
thing
right that's what we're afraid of yeah
because there's no progression and no
pain to move him off a dead center so
um it might be that that's what his
wake-up call is and you've heard a oh
story his dad kicked him out he lived in
his car
yeah because he was he was a smart ankle
and smart off at his mother
and uh you know run up a bunch of debt
and got kicked out of school and they
threw him out and he lived in his car
for a year
but his dad checked with him every week
and made sure he was okay but let him
live in his car
you know and so and yeah you know a.o
tell you that's the best thing ever
happened to him
um when he and but when he did say all
right dad i'm ready to straighten up and
come home first thing he handed him was
a dave ramsey budget and he got on it by
god then
you know because he was because he's his
little his little tail was ready but
that's a o's story uh you know in a
nutshell and so i'm thinking
the thing you don't want to do with this
is just abandon him
to himself i still want to keep i still
want to keep as much love
and influence over him as i possibly can
by constantly extending
not help that enables
not help that causes him to continue on
the same path but any
sign that's positive i'm going to meet
him on that sign
and you know he goes and gets a job dad
i want to try to get out of that good if
you
start working on your debts i'll pay
some of it i'll pay you know
i'll match whatever you put on your dad
or uh mom i'm gonna start doing a budget
and
okay come over and sit down we'll have
dinner and i'll show you and i'll coach
you with this and i'll meet with you
over coffee once a week and you're not
abandoning him
that's my point okay and that yeah
that would make this the only way it's
tolerable for me emotionally
it's real hard yeah candace i i like
dave's idea of the letter i would add
a section in there on what you and your
husband have noticed about him his
brightest moments in life whether been
on the sporting field
or in the classroom or at a science fair
this is when you're your best
yeah and this is what we see and you've
got all this potential this teacher
said in the sixth grade about you i
would remind him of his tremendous value
and i would also say hey we believe
there's a unique role that you were put
on this planet to fill
and we will help you get there but this
is an agreement and you know wonder if
you want to put in there but i would i
would show a lot of value there and let
him see that
uh and then i think i love dave's point
on checking in when he wakes up in his
own vomit after partering
partying all night that letter's laying
there that's right and he remembers the
value
he remembers his value i'm just curious
real quick has he ever shared a dream
with you
for his future um
yeah he has a well i don't know if i
necessarily
a hundred percent align with it but i
didn't ask you that
what do you say yeah his dream um is he
wants to go into business
um in the dispensary business because in
california you know marijuana is legal
um so but he likes the medicinal
purposes of it and so he wants to go
into that
world but you have to be 21. so for him
he just wants a way to get free pot that
has nothing to do with it
really what it you is
i've been encouraging him to um you know
he
you know he got offered a job to work um
as like an activity director
for you know uh old um older elderly
people home
yeah are you guys are you guys in a good
church candace are y'all in a good
church
yeah i am he's my son hate or miss on if
he goes no your husband too
my husband does not go no i think you
all ought to get some people in your
corner
that are walking this out with you
because you're going to have idiots say
this is tough love and it's not tough
love it's just love
tough love is no different than love
love has boundaries to it
and as for me and my house we don't do
things this way
and so you can't live here if you're
gonna do this this way that's what
you're saying
and because you love him but be there
for him don't abandon him in this
process